I'm about to play stockfish 16 the
strongest chess computer in the world
and we are going to see how long I can
survive what what the fu is that yeah
I'm fine I'm not fine Queen takes bishop
checkmate that was horrible I never want
to do that again I got checkmated in 34
moves the most important thing is I had
a lot of fun no I didn't my name is Levy
Rosman I want to find out a little bit
more about how stockfish thinks so I can
use its tricks to beat other humans
today we'll talk to Gary lincot software
engineer who has worked in computer
chess for over 20 years so Gary you
worked on stockfish what exactly makes
it so good stockfish really takes
advantage of super powerful computers it
searches tens of millions of Physicians
per second so if you give it 30 seconds
it's going to be searching upwards of a
billion positions and that's more
positions than a human will see in their
entire lifetime I could live a hundred
lifetimes I would not be able to win
this game not only that the evaluation
function it uses its way of assessing
the board by itself is probably stronger
than almost all the chess players in the
world your chess ELO is basically a
number that quantifies your skill level
the highest ever ELO achieved by a human
is by Magnus Carlson my ELO right now is
2322 what exactly is stock fish's ELO
right now it's probably greater than
3500 I never had a chance to understand
how stockfish actually thinks we should
start at the very beginning of the game
most chess openings are subjective for
humans a human will choose an opening
because they get more fun out of it you
might like something because it gives
you a big Center or very active pieces
that's how most players choose their
openings in my game against stockfish I
played Pawn to D4 let's see which
opening stockfish plays and it responded
Knight to F6 Gary so the way humans
learn chess openings we read books we
create chess files and we try to
memorize them cuz we can't access them
during tournament games that would be
like cheating on a school test an
opening book in chess is a gigantic
chess database does stockfish have a
chess opening opinion as as early as the
second or even first move the way that
it thinks about the opening is really
different than a human it is not using
chess Theory it very rarely assesses an
opening position what it's assessing is
the resulting structures that might
evolve from that opening but way way
down the game tree it's already
assessing the end game right from the
GetGo so on its second move stockfish
played D5 which is a very popular move
and here I made a decision to capture
this Knight humans might see doubled PA
and feel unpleasant they might see a
weakness in their position does
stockfish have these little buzzwords
like weakness or inactive piece what
actually goes into that the evaluation
function is trained off of a huge
library of chess games that have been
played and so it kind of absorbs that
knowledge it's just all going into a
giant neural net and then you can train
your evaluation function to learn what's
good and what's bad and then that
network runs when stockfish is searching
the position and and uses it to navigate
the opening so to succeed in our quest
of understanding stockfish a little bit
better let's dive into middle games most
middle games begin around move 10 to 15
it's the stage right after the opening
when you've gotten all your pieces out
you can think of the middle game and
chess as a gigantic ocean this massive
tree of possibilities so in my middle
game against stockfish Pawn to C4 is
what I played stockfish played a move
that I don't think any human being would
play here against me the Absurd Pawn to
G5 which made me audibly G
what is that oh my God is that actually
the best move in the position that move
violates most human chess principles
that we have been brought up with you
shouldn't push Pawns in front of your
king you should not weaken an area of
the board where you can't claim any
advantage how does stockfish break these
age-old principles in this case it might
just be that the move is too far past
kind of the human Frontier to be a
reasonable one it's going to assess
every possible move and it's going to
rank them it all comes down to a single
number which is what's the likelihood
that I'm going to win from this position
stockfish doesn't have emotions and
opinions it will just play the best move
that it thinks exists yes stockfish
definitely does not emotionally consider
it it is assessing with like grandmas
level quality but it then searches 50
moves 60 moves into the future to
evaluate what is the best possible move
I'm curious like as an incredibly strong
human how many moves do you search into
the future I didn't realize this was the
roast of Levy Rosman sometimes I can go
10 moves if it's an endgame position and
I can kind of identify the forcing moves
for both sides sometimes I'm stuck in a
middle game and I'm already indecisive
it's like being at a restaurant you have
three good options they're all very
difficult to evaluate and I'll flip a
coin but that doesn't work against
stockfish I counted in this position
black has 41 legal moves how does
stockfish know which of those to scrub
and ultimately decide on one if three or
four look really really good it builds a
game tree and that game tree is going to
have all the legal moves it's going to
rank all of those moves it takes one
step forward at a time it'll search two
moves ahead then three moves ahead then
four moves ahead three or four moves
speak to me in about 5 seconds and
that's probably why I'm a good speed
chest player but deciding on the best
move sometimes I need to spend 5 minutes
10 minutes uncovering the truth about
one of those moves chess computers
actually do a similar sort of process
stockfish actually only looks at about
two moves per position and that's what's
called the alpha beta search technique
which is what stockfish and most other
engines are built on top of Alpha Beta
allows the engine to eliminate many many
moves from a position because it knows
that they are worse than the best move
that it's found so far and that allows
Alpha Beta to prune a huge amount of the
search trees for example if it was
White's move one of the legal moves is
Knight to E4 which is really really
stupid because the pawn would take the
Knight and white would be at a
catastroph rically worse position some
computers will just be able to discard
this right away and humans will too
Alpha Beta by itself can take those 35
moves that you have to look at on
average down to about 15 or so which is
a huge reduction the last stage of Chess
is the end game is there any difference
in the way that stockfish approaches the
end game versus the middle game or the
opening yes once the number of pieces
goes below a certain amount seven then
stockfish can actually solve the game
perfectly
chess is solved if there are seven
pieces remaining on a chess board or
less exactly yeah there's what are
called endgame table bases and by solved
we mean literally every combination of
moves possible if the bishop goes here
and the Knight goes here or if the
bishop goes to that square originally
and the Knight goes there or there or
there or any of these combinations all
of that is solved literally stockfish
just has to look up the position in its
database and it knows exactly what the
answer is even for for seven pieces it's
only about 10 to 20 terab of data which
is a lot but you know manageable there
is no more evaluating a best move is the
best move in a position is either
winning a draw or losing and that's it
it's completely non-negotiable exactly
now the chess computers are capable of
playing without the table bases as well
and they will still play incredibly
strong chess there but they could make a
mistake Gary I lost to stockfish I got
checkmated in 34 moves we didn't make
get into an end game all right but
that's just as well stockfish always
knows how to close out a game in the
least amount of moves even when the
world's greatest players don't I have a
game here Magnus Carlson versus Fabiano
Carana from the 2018 World Chess
Championship Magnus was in an end game
where he was down a piece but neither
one of them found the right technique
Fabiano has a bishop and a knight and
Magnus only has a bishop Fabiano could
not convert despite his extra material
because it looked like Magnus had a
defensive Fortress the game ended in a
draw while the play players were playing
and the entire world was watching
stockfish was screaming at them from the
digital cyberspace going you idiots forc
Checkmate in 35 moves that is ridiculous
like how could it have possibly known
that if both sides made a move for 35
moves black would win what stockfish can
do is look forward into the table bases
and every path to the table bases the
best that you can possibly do is that M
35 if stockfish was playing Black here
instead of Fabiano it would have played
Bishop to H four then bring its Knight
here and then trap its own Knight on the
edge of the board so the Knight now
cannot Escape anywhere because White's
Bishop would take it no human being
would play chess like this you cannot
trap your knight on the edge of the
board but apparently white actually runs
out of moves first and slowly but surely
black would have won that endgame
stockfish saw that from a distance no
human on the planet saw that so
stockfish is a very very specialized AI
how does it compare to to some other AIS
autonomous cars or something else
stockfish is only good at one thing and
it's super good at that one thing which
is playing chess chess engines have now
borrowed the state-of-the-art research
in artificial intelligence which is deep
learning however they're still
fundamentally limited to the domain of
chess chess has I think been opened up
in a way by AI people can Leverage The
Chess engines to improve their own
skills and that's kind of like the ideal
use case for Technologies is that they
help humans you know do things better I
agree with Gary I think AI has been a
net benefit for chess I think it's
helping people improve at a rate like
we've never experienced we do obviously
have to tackle the issue of potential
cheating but I'm going to stay positive
and optimistic anyway now that I know a
little bit more about stockfish I'm
going to go have my
rematch